alors on passe maintenant à notre
campagne électorale fédérale
al'approche du débat en français demain
jeudi c'est le port du niqab qui semble
qui s'amuse à poser comme sujet pour les
chefs demain probablement en particulier
à cause de l'enjeu
ce que cela représente comme enjeu au
québec en particulier c'est un débat en
français le premier comme vous le savez
donc on a posé la question à deux des
chefs ce matin thomas mulcair qui se
s'en remet toujours au jugement de la
cour fédérale pour ce qui est de
l'immédiat on l'a talonné la sur
l'avenir si les conservateurs par
exemple qui promettent de le faire
adopte une veulent faire adopter une loi
qui règlerait la question une fois pour
toute et qu'il interdirait vous allez
voir comment s'est prononcé on l'a
talonné là dessus mais stephen harper
lui a été interrogé et on va l'attendre
également sur l'utilisation éventuelle
de la clause dérogatoire qui est prévu
dans la constitution pour protéger une
telle loi monsieur harper n'a pas voulu
s'aventurer sur ce terrain là il a
simplement défendu sa position de base
on peut les entendre tous la loi dit en
ce moment qu'une femme qui porte un
voile est obligé de se dévoiler de se
découvrir pour prêter serment et je suis
d'accord avec ça c'est ça qui est écrit
dans la loi
au delà de ça le jugement concerne le
droit individuel et c'est ça qui est
garanti donc un gouvernement peut pas
enlever votre liberté d'expression ou sa
liberté de presse pas plus qu'on peut
interférer dans ses autres libertés
comprends parfaitement est une question
sensible au québec
est ce que vous seriez d'accord pour
interdire de prêter serment avec un
niqab
pas plus que je voterai en faveur d'une
loi qui vous enlèverait la liberté de
presse
voyons noms des nouveaux citoyens
doivent doivent être doivent apprendre
la cérémonie de citoyenneté à visage
découvert c'est ça c'est ça reflète nos
valeurs et l'égalité des hommes et des
femmes au canada
au sujet du conservateur une promesse de
don à la fondation terry fox les maisons
une histoire un peu complexe annonce
dimanche par james moore un ministre qui
ne revient pas dans la course
actuellement en compagnie de rennes on
peut d'ailleurs de d'un fonds de
contrepartie pour tous les dons qui sont
donnés en ce 35e anniversaire c'était
dimanche de la course terry fox
il y en a plus de 700 travers le pays la
famille dit contrairement à ce que dit
monsieur moore on n'a pas entendu de
manière enthousiaste appuyer cette
initiative là on en a pas attendu par
les conservateurs là-dessus
reconnaissent leurs erreurs mais il
reste que la fondation et c'est ça que
monsieur harper a expliqué ce matin la
fondation terry fox avait demandé un
certain soutien éventuellement pour une
nouvelle initiative de la création d'un
nouveau centre de cancer intégré au pays
donc l'explication de stephen harper
c'est qu'on a une demande est en hausse
marquée lui trouve qu on politise
littéralement un monument canadien qui
les écoutent encore
le rythme ralentit un peu avant le débat
d'après là mais j'en ai quand même fait
des annonces jouit monsieur marqueur sur
l'assurance-emploi grosses améliorations
360 heures de lors des 52 dernières
semaines de travail seulement pour les
nouveaux arrivants et la réintégration
du marché du travail ainsi que pour ceux
qui sont congédiés contrôleur leurs
voeux c'est beaucoup plus bas que les
minimum actuel est actuellement ce
justin trudeau est à montréal lui des
engagements en culture en a on double le
financement du conseil d'état ces 180
millions de plus radio canada 150
millions de plus sur une base annuelle
et aussi du financement additionnel du
côté de l'ol f et de téléfilm canada
voilà toutes les institutions
culturelles canadiennes à la veille d'un
débat en français au québec puis sa
personne au coude droit